I cannot believe you get to be in the
front row to watch these guys every
night well they think about a rough my
kids are gonna go to college because
their dad had to sit and watch Steph
Curry play for a living life is very
very good when that happens that's for
sure you know what's funny Bob is when
we were doing NFL games together
whatever it was four or five years ago
you know Golden State was just average
and I would talk to you about man what's
that like you know NBA they don't give
great effort all the time and you said
hey every night I see something that
just makes your jaw drop now Bob you see
something that makes your jaw drop
pretty much every possession it's the
craziest thing I've ever seen well the
thing about it Ross is that you know the
boyars now are linked with the Jordan
Bulls and when you watch Michael Jordan
and you watch LeBron James and Karl
Malone you see these physical size and
skill and things that are just hard to
comprehend but you say way that guy's 66
that guy 68 Steph Curry's 63 a buck 80
and he walks amongst us as a normal
human being now you played the NFL any
play doh line so maybe you're a bigger
guy in the first place but there's
relatability to stefan from grandparents
two grandkids two guys girls teenagers
people that play basketball the whole
bid and he does things from a skill
level in a shooting level that really
are hard to comprehend and much like
Jordan was this transcendent figure who
is on a pantheon by himself Steph is
there I mean he's very close and he's
you know he's just shooting the
basketball like no one we've ever seen
in the game and then a will and an
ability to dominate we're okay you're in
San Antonio it's the worst building he's
ever played in in terms of stats it's
the toughest shooting it's against the
best defensive team it's against a team
is undefeated at home
and he rolls out 37 to the tie the Bulls
with 72 wins and he is now going to be
the first MVP to increase his scoring by
the largest margin in NBA history
surpassing Larry Bird so it just is
amazing to watch it's super fun and all
other the Beatles when they travel know
it's like Michael Jackson met
Springsteen met Justin Bieber met Selena
when we travel it's just unreal people
show up two hours early to watch Steph
Curry warm up it's like the first time
we had basketball batting practice where
there's several thousand people in the
building yeah I was gonna say that we're
talking about Fitzgerald's gonna ask you
that he's the golden state warriors TV
play-by-play man a good buddy of mine
Notre Dame grad I might add and I'm
curious Bob what is it like because you
know you're on the team playing you
travel with the team what is it like
give me some examples give me some
stories of what it's like the team hotel
I can't even imagine right now well I'll
give you two of them is that we were at
a dinner in Philadelphia and the
Warriors were on a lower level of this
restaurant and from the upper level in a
balcony a father and son had like a
fishing rod and they had a little card
with a pen it said steph would you
please sign this and they lowered the
card like via the fishing rod from the
upper deck down to the lower tech ulit
stressed rod so Steph's got a piece of
steak in his mouth and all of a sudden
this card is being lowered down by a
fishing rod please sign this now I
thought that was pretty ingenious and
pretty funny we were at a hotel on the
road a couple months ago and the players
for someone like when the NFL travels
but the NBA players floor in a hotel is
usually the guys on our team a part of
our traveling party and the players are
put on the same floor and some
enterprising teenagers had secured the
room next to the elevator on this floor
well in advance somehow and they have
the door kind of cracked open and so
every time a warrior would come down the
hallway to go the elevator for whatever
you know shoot around or the team
breakfast or just to go out
they would pop out of their room to take
pictures and get autographs until this
team finally had to tell hotel security
hey wait a minute there 66 teenagers in
this hotel room but basically have uh
have scoped out the warrior locale here
so you know three in the morning in
Cleveland you arrived in there's 2,000
people wait outside the hotel and it's
10 degrees outside you know you just you
I've been in the league 22 years I've
never seen anything like it yeah I don't
picture it ending anytime soon Bob I
mean I don't know how this would affect
your job and if it affects it a lot that
I don't want it to happen but i honestly
think Bob that the NBA should put them
on national television every game next
year I mean that's they're the only team
in the NBA that I will stop and I will
watch because I want to watch and it's
not just staff I mean he's the ease the
main guy but just the way they play
overall it's just so fun to watch what
do you think about my theory putting
them on national TV every night well i
mean first of all you're perceptive you
know princeton guy would not surprise me
is that you know the Warriors are
blowing through every TV record there is
you know just just an idea not to bore
people but csn bay area here in San
Francisco the fourth largest market and
when the Giants in 2010 clinched against
the san diego padres they have a 10.6
rating the sunday game against San
Antonio the Warriors did an 18.9 Wow and
so the top 15 events in the history of
this network are all warrior games from
this year the game also sunday was the
largest viewed game in the history of
NBA TV and so you're really you're
getting two record-setting interest
levels and we're not even to tomorrow
and I where they go for 73 so yes
between ESPN and T CSN Bay Area you are
not alone in really the commonality much
like tiger in golf probably that
everyone says I'm kind of in the NBA but
I'm really interested in the Warriors
and to become kind of America
team when we travel or people want to
watch because of steve kerr and the
leadership and the unselfishness and the
way they play and they're good
offensively they're good defensively and
they're good guys and they get along and
they have fun and they're ascending into
their prime because nobody on the team
as a core player is old and so it
couldn't go on for quite some time and
it really is special it's like almost
what a high school team would be and
that is Steph Curry setting the tone
like a Tim Duncan did with San Antonio
when your superstar is in the mix like
when you play with Tom Brady you know
Tom's a transcendent player but also one
of the guys and that's hard for four
stars you always talk about the alpha
male in the NBA Steph Curry he kicks it
with all 12 guys on the roster and you
can't teach that how important is it to
them to break the record I mean watching
them sunday night it looked like this is
something that they really want to do
you know draymond Green started this a
couple weeks ago and I got to tell you
the red wings had the record and didn't
win the cup the Patriots went 16 and 0
didn't win the Super Bowl the Mariners
won 116 games didn't win the World
Series only the bowl that 72 and 10 went
on to win the championship so my idea
was why are they sprinting in mile 21 of
a marathon this record your head be
great but you gotta rest guys he had be
smart about minutes you don't want
anybody getting hurt i mean this gotta
win for seven games serious to win an
NBA championship why would you want this
and draymond Green kind of came out
publicly and said I want to be known as
a winner that s that's what I want at
the end of my career I want to be known
as a winner and if we win 73 that's the
greatest winner or winning team in the
history of the sport and will never be
this close again a year ago they won 67
games 10 teams of 167 in 70 years every
one of those teams one fewer games the
year after the Warriors are the first
team of those ten to exceed their win
total and so dream on publicly said I
don't need to rest I want this
want to be a winner and he told the guys
the team has a group chat that they text
everybody's on it they just said if you
need to rest or you're dinged up where I
was totally cool but I want to go for
this and everybody kind of jumped on his
shoulders and said yeah let's do it and
then that's kind of been their mindset
song with Bob Fitzgerald he's the
play-by-play guy for the golden state
warriors out there on csn bay area Bob
who's the biggest threat you watched
this team every game who's the biggest
threat in your opinion from them winning
the title this year well you know Rob's
mean last year it was that the route was
New Orleans Memphis Houston Cleveland
and now with the results last night it's
going to be there utah or houston in the
first round probably Houston so you
think about 47 games series Harden and
Dwight Howard and forever a reason and
Corey Brewer and a rocket team that was
in the Western finals you have to play
them in round one then Blake Griffin and
Chris Paul and a clipper team that's now
top three defensively that's round two
then the San Antonio Spurs 19 straight
50 win seasons five championships
Popovich Duncan Parker Ginobili Kawhi
Leonard LaMarcus Aldridge that's round
three and then you might get LeBron
again with Kyrie Irving and Kevin Love
in round four wow I mean that that route
to a championship would be incredibly
difficult but what you get back to is
can any of those teams beat the Golden
State Warriors in a seven-game series
right you know that you know they can
they can make them bleed a minute you
know they can grab a game or two but
this team is 39 and two in each of the
last at home in the last two seasons you
the Warriors are 34 and seven on the
road that's the most road wins ever in
NBA history they're gonna get one in
your building and so that means you
gotta beat them twice in their building
I don't know if the math works on that I
think though I think they will be tested
you know two years ago Dallas in a 18
matchup took the Spurs to seven games in
round one that's not difficult to
Western Conference's so you know they
they
could stumble because of this tremendous
effort to get this record but is the
team going to beat them four times in a
seven-game series I don't know man I
mean they're a pretty special team on
offense and defense and team chemistry
why's that they're healthy right now I
would like the Warriors chances in a lot
of those series and a lot of those
matchups so what's the long-term threat
here Bob you know for them not being
like this for the next four or five
years what what can prevent this team
from being you know going on you know an
epic run over the next few years
anything you know how Riley with the
Lakers you know he talked about the
disease of me and that's where people
start to worry about their fame and
their endorsements and their contracts
and you know what about me and where do
I fit in and jealousy and you know that
this person gets too much shine and I
don't get enough with the Warriors I
don't see that you know what with Steph
Curry being the MVP and the under armour
spokesman and having all the endorsement
klay Thompson is the perfect Batman
Robin he's an elite player and doesn't
really seek the limelight draymond Green
is the the heartbeat in the passion of
the team but if you get seven of those
guys would be crazy but you got one
you've got tremendous veterans like
Andre Iguodala and Andrew Bogut and the
general manager for the Warriors Bob
Meyers used to work for Arn Tellem is a
phenomenal player agent before I became
a GM they staggered the contracts and so
you don't have five guys coming up for
free agency all at the same time and
they've paid on riga dalla and andrew
bogut and then klay Thompson and
draymond Green and after next year
Stephan curry will come up so I think
structurally they're in good shape they
have an ownership in Joe Lacob and Peter
Guber that right to check every time so
that it won't be the lack of money the
team is moving into a new arena in san
francisco in 2019 the fan base they've
sold out you know for almost 200 games
and counting I don't know that something
gets derailed other than you know sports
you know it's a knee injury or a back
injury or for the kill ease injury or
something to a key player but no they
should be in the mix you know for a long
time and and the Spurs real
the barometer 19 years of excellence
five championships in that run you know
the Patriots are a barometer I mean
teams that are just in the hunt every
single year and I think this is four
straight playoff years for the Warriors
that's the goal you're not going to win
a title every year but be one of those
teams where you're in the hunt
legitimately every single season and as
long as Steph Curry is kind of leading
the way you'd have to say that they're
going to be there really appreciate the
time keep having fun man I'm happy for
you that they are this good thanks so
much a Roffe anytime great talking to
you and tell them you know I was in
London with him for the NBC olympics
he's always been one of my favorites
just an honor to be on the show the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience